[Music]
everybody is Charlie we finally got a
look at Mysterio in spider-man bar from
home so there's all kinds of stuff we
have to break down I'm still doing that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a spider-man related comment
on the video probably freaking out about
Mysterio so what's going on here
obviously they're just continuing to
film this extended fight scene between
spider-man Mysterio that we've been
talking about for the past week or so
spider-man is still wearing his black
costume Mysterio in a full text suit
which obviously flows a lot from the
tech energy that you saw during
homecoming like the vulture based on
tech all trickling down from shatori
tech during that big Avengers battle of
New York like even though spider-man's
villains are mostly animal themed
they're all influenced by tech mostly it
won't be till we get x-men and mutants
in the MCU that we'll see more
biological powers but I'll try to
reference that later too because that
gets into a Norman Osborn spider-man
obviously has biological powers because
of the spider bite but I think one of
the coolest things here though is is
that we actually get a version of comic
book fishbowl Mysterio so obviously he's
not wearing it right here but there's a
lot of people that have been saying him
walking around on said there's a version
of the fishbowl as realistic a version
as you could do in a film like this
so it wouldn't expect it to look exactly
like you see it in the comics like it
does look a little bit silly so it'll
probably be toned down just a little bit
but everybody was wondering about what
was going on with Jake Gyllenhaal he'd
been rumored as Mysterio for so long
these pictures even though the footage
is a little grainy these pictures just
confirm that he is Mysterio during the
film they do get stunt doubles for the
really dangerous scenes but it looks
like they've already done that and
they're filming more close-up shots in
this fight here like he's up close to
him they're actually like punching each
other in the face so usually when
there's big explosions or during like
the Coney Island battle at the end of
homecoming then they incorporate a lot
of special effects in green-screen so
like Michael Keaton himself was never
actually standing near open flame that
was all done later in post-production so
this actual big carnival fight doesn't
seem like it's going to be their last
battle from the movie but because scenes
for movies are filmed out of order
there's no way to tell when all the
characters go to the Czech Republic but
I'm guessing because they start their
slow progression on the
field trip that they're on across Europe
in London that London is relatively
early in the film then they make their
way to Venice then they make their way
to Prague that's where they're supposed
to be right here even though they're not
actually filming in Prague this is
doubling for a carnival in Prague Czech
Republic so it is cool that they're
trying to film as much of this in the
real world as possible but you have to
imagine they're gonna beef this up in
post-production a lot so they'll
probably way more stuff going on in the
background and even though a lot of the
scenes that we've seen with Spider Man
in his black costume are practical with
a version of Tom Holland and his stunt
double running around on this set they
will probably be a lot of CG spider-man
web slinging around that they'll add
later when they do special effects the
funny thing about Jake Gyllenhaal in
this scene too is that he's got the same
beard that makes him look almost exactly
like the pictures everyone was posting
of him earlier this year when he was
first rumored to be in talks for the
film way before they were ever filming
any of this so it's almost like Marvel
told him well we want you to seem a
little bit older than spider-man because
Jake Gyllenhaal seems pretty young when
he's clean-shaven could you please keep
that beard that you have in all the
pictures that people have been posting
of you all year long I think it's a
pretty good choice like they still want
spider-man to seem like he's really
really young this is supposed to be
during his junior year in high school so
even though some time has passed since
what's happened during the Avengers
Infinity Ward Avengers 4 movies he's put
on a whole lot of city miles he's still
sort of a kid fighting these other big
sinister six characters so the drone in
the background that you also see flying
through this scene with the green lights
on it it could just be a camera that
they're using on set to capture more
footage of this big battle or it could
just be a reference for something that
they'll replace with Mysterio tech later
in CG because remember Mysterio he's a
special-effects wizard he'll be using a
lot of theatricality in his fight with
spider-man and during the film the
really cool meta thing I think too about
them using the Quentin Beck version is
that you talk a lot about the big
special effects that people use in these
Marvel movies especially with infinity
war Quentin Beck is a master of movie
special effects that's where he came
from before he became a criminal so it
becomes this really cool meta thing so
it'll be interesting to see where he
gets a lot of his technology from if
they go back to the tinkerer or if
there's someone else that he's pirating
tech from there's still a big question
about how there
use infinity war and Avengers 4 to
influence what goes on in the future of
the MCU because homecoming made really
good use of the Battle of New York like
there was all this alien tech leftover
from the shoot our invasion so it'll be
really interesting to see if any of the
new spider-man villains going forward
use anything that's left over from
infinity war and Avengers for a lot of
that will just depend on the way that
they fix things at the end of Avengers 4
but when we learned about this big
carnival scene last week I did a video
about the black suit spider-man vs.
Mysterio fighting each other at a
carnival in the classic comic books I'll
link that at the end of this because
there are a lot of Easter eggs and
references for spider-man's original
comic book battles with Mysterio but in
the way that homecoming changed a lot
about his original battles with the
vulture they're gonna do the same thing
with far from home there'll be a lot of
cool comic book Easter eggs but a lot of
the story will just be built on what
they've done so far in the MCU that's
the beauty that sony's sharing
arrangement they can use plot devices
from other movies that aren't
necessarily spider-man like Avengers in
the Battle of New York so theory time
now that we know that Jake Gyllenhaal is
playing Mysterio we can throw out a
couple of other villain theories that
I've seen pop up in the last couple of
days it was so funny yesterday when this
video dropped a couple of websites I saw
a pop up in my feed we're trying to
suggest that maybe he was playing Norman
Osborn secretly in JB's smooth another
actor was playing Mysterio but then
right after they were posting that below
that post this video popped in my feed
so if immediately born theory then died
on the vine within a couple of seconds
of each other so it should be said that
I don't think that there's any weird
trickery going on here I definitely
think that Jake Gyllenhaal is playing
Mysterio and he is fighting a version of
Peter Parker in a black costume they're
not trying to trick us or anything like
that but there are other members of the
sinister six that have been confirmed
for the film vulture the Mac Gargan
scorpion from homecoming the original
chameleons from the comics who was the
stepbrother of Kraven the hunter then
there were rumors about a fifth member
hydro-man now technically he wasn't
really a member of the sinister six but
you have to imagine five big villain is
showing up who's the six obviously
they're building towards sinister six
eventually it was the scene that Tom
Holland posted
a spider-man fight scene with someone in
the Venice canals of him getting blasted
with water doesn't necessarily confirm
hydro-man could have just been Mysterio
but what I think is going on is because
Jake Gyllenhaal is such a big actor and
he's playing such a classic character I
still think that he's the main villain
of spider-man far from home and he'll be
orchestrating or be behind anything else
that the other sinister six comic book
characters are doing in the movie early
post credits scene theory though after
spider-man has won the day defeated them
they're in jail one or more of them meet
and discuss forming an official
quote-unquote team aka the MCU version
of the sinister six in that sort of your
tip-off that there will be a third film
and it will be a legit sinister six film
and while they have enough high caliber
actors and a-list villains to do a
sinister six movie without Norman Osborn
Green Goblin it kind of feels wrong to
leave him out of things completely but
post all your theories in the comments
below
there's all kinds of Marvel stuff
happening this week with New York Comic
Cons so I'll leave the giveaway open all
week long I'll just remind people when I
post my next Marvel video but click here
for that other spider-man far from home
black costume video and click here for a
new ant-man in the wasp Avengers for
deleted scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]